after many years of petting
every dog she ever encountered she
finally got her own dog
it's yeti a seven-month-old bernadoodle
and she is very excited for that for
that dog
so please welcome emily robinson
hi everyone very excited to be here uh
as jared said i now have a second dog
who is currently running around behind
me uh his name is yeti
uh yeah but very excited to be here uh
even virtually thank you all for joining
and today i'll be talking about funnel
join
defining a tidy grammar of funnels in r
so before i start i want to you know
establish well what is a funnel
uh exactly and how to find a
set of events by users over time
so for example let's say you're an
e-commerce company redesigning the
homepage of your website
before doing so if you're a product
manager an analyst you might have some
questions that would inform this design
like what's the last page people visit
before coming to the home page
but all the product pages people see
after the home page
or how many people who visit the home
page go on to buy something
what if we limit that to buy within two
days
so those are all different kinds of
first this than that questions
and that's an example of uh online
behavior but it doesn't necessarily need
to be that
it doesn't even need to be people so for
example
you could ask which salmon migrated to
station one then station three before
station 2.
what drugs did people take in the last
month before starting drug x
what was the last ad clicked before
registering so these are all different
types of questions where you're asking
okay i want to know
what happened you know in in what
sequence
uh of events what companies have their
stock hit a hundred dollars per share
then drop to 40.
so let's take one of those examples of
let's say we want to know when a user's
first landing was and their first
registration afterward
so if we have these two example
data sets you know these are pretty
small we have a landed table and a
registered table so
these have the user ids of who did the
landing or the registration
and the time stamp in this case today
that they did it
now you know if you ask this question
you could probably do it and maybe your
workflow would look something like this
so you'd first filter to get the first
landing
per user then you'd left join with
registrations based on user id
you'd filter for only those
registrations that happened
after the landing or when there's no
registration and then finally
you need to only get their first
registration afterwards so
again you'd have to arrange and then get
the distinctions you only have one row
per user
so this is doable but that's a fair
amount of steps
and let's say you slightly change the
question
to who registered the first time ever
after their last landing
so now again we keep the first step of
we filter landed for the last row per
user
we've switched it up now to the last
instead of the first
then we need to left join but we need to
left join on registrations
only on people's first registrations
and then we need to again filter for the
registration time
time being after the landing or there
not being
a landing so this is possible but you
can imagine there is a bunch of like
fragile steps here right what if you
forget to switch it to descending
for the landing what if you forget to do
a distinct for the registration
so there's just a lot of places that
errors can be introduced
with uh you know having this much code
and needing to change you know a fair
amount between
the exact type of question you're asking
so that's why i created the funnel join
package along with david robinson and
anthony baker
so you can find funnel join on my github
robinson es and it's also on cran
so funnel join is about making these
types of questions
easier by defining a function
to do this and defining specific types
of exact registrations
oh exactly sorry exact funnels so the
goal of this talk is that previously
you might have been like this with
funnels where you had
you know you you'd be willing to do it
but it would be a little difficult
for those of you who don't know this is
cinderblock and poor cinderblock came to
the shelter pretty overweight
so you know they had to get her on a
exercise plan but as you can see she was
not especially enthusiastic about this
now after this talk you'll be taking
your first steps
you'll be figuring out okay i can now
you know start tackling these types of
questions using this new package funnel
join
and then because funnel join is i
promise you
so is is straightforward and i would
like to think fairly well documented
after this you'll just be sailing over
problems
no issues
so let's take an overview of the package
so the main function in funnel joint is
after join
which asks uh which is defines this
grammar so let's take that question of
when was
each user's first landing and their
first registration afterward
so this is what the funnel join workflow
looks like
so let's break it down step by step so
first we have
the first two tables so we have the
landed and the registration table
and the first table is the one that's
the you know first event what happens
first
and the second table is what happens
after then we define
what is the user column name so in this
case basically what's the link what's
the identifier that links these events
together
in our case it's user id then we have
what are the time
column names in our case time stamp and
finally the type of after join
and so the type is one is what's really
powerful
about funnel join because the type
argument specifies okay what
what type of funnel do we want in this
case we want
someone's first landing and their first
registration
afterward
so there's a couple different types of
funnels that we can have
let's take some examples so this is a
person
george who has some ad clicks and
conversion events on a website
and so i've colored it here where green
is conversion and blue are at clicks and
so left to right it goes over
you know a series of time so let's say
we have the question what is george's
first ad click and his first conversion
afterward
so again this is the first first after
and here we're linking
the first the first blue square the add
click to the first conversion afterward
but maybe instead we want to know what's
his most recent ad click and all the
conversions afterward
so here we take the last ad click and we
link it to
both conversions that happen afterward
and this is a last any
because we want the last ad click and we
want any conversions afterward
and finally maybe we want the biggest
funnel possible we want all of the ad
clicks and all of the conversions
afterward so we draw all of these links
between
every ad click and all the conversions
afterward and this isn't any any join
so these are three different funnels and
these are
the only thing you have to change in the
code of after join
is that type argument that's saying what
type of funnel do you want
and there are 16 types of funnels that
you can define
so they are any combination of for the
first table first
last any and last before and for the
second table
first last any and first after
so let's do a demo
so i'm going to be analyzing stack
overflow questions that are tagged with
r
if you want to download this yourself
you can go to kaggle
where they have this data set so here
i'm going to take
both the questions and the answers data
sets
so these are questions tagged with r and
the answers for them
and we can see they have the things that
we need they have an owner user id the
person who asked the question or gave
the answer
and they have the time the creation date
that they did so
so those are the two components we need
to use funnel join
so let's ask how many people who ask a
question
later answer one so this is
just as we've been seeing before a first
first after
so because we only want one row per user
uh we want just first because otherwise
you know for example if we had any we
could have
many rows per user if they ask multiple
questions so let's just get the first
question they ask
and the first one that they answer
afterward
we're doing a left join so we're making
sure to keep all the people who ask
questions regardless if they answer
and we're linking on creation date and
owner user id
and just a little trick here with a
suffix so this was actually something i
didn't know before i
was creating this package but deep flyer
offers this as well
if you want the columns that aren't
joined on but are common between the
tables if you don't want them to have
like dot x and dot y as their suffix you
can actually define
and say in this case i want underscore
question underscore answer
so then we can do summarize conversions
and this is another function in funnel
join
where we can uh say okay let's
um take this table so this table would
have been a very long table with all the
questions and whether or not they had an
answer
and let's just summarize it to answer
this question in this case
i want to get the percent that i'm going
to call it converted
and i do this by saying converted equals
id answer so if they have an
entry for id answer which they'll only
have if they answered a question
uh then count it if not don't and so we
can see in the summary
that we had 60 000 users uh
13688 answered a question
which is 22.7
now how long does it take for people to
answer their first question
so what we have here in funnel join is
another argument
called gap call and if we set it to true
it will add a column dot gap
which is the length of time in seconds
between
uh the two events so in this case length
of time between a question and an answer
and i'm going to mutate that two hours
just to make a little bit easier
and we can get a graph from that so we
can see that
uh in this case there is uh some people
who
you know answered within an hour a lot
more within a day
a week or you know some people wait a
month or more
what about what percent answer within a
week of asking their first question
so you know we could work with the
data we had before where we got that gap
column
to answer this but again funnel joint
offers a bit of an easier way to do this
which is you can set a max gap
argument so the max gap argument can
take either
a diff time object in this case we're
saying one week
or it can take an integer in
which is the number of seconds so here
i'm saying okay i
only want to join if there
is a gap of a maximum a week
and so in this case if someone answered
a question after a month it would not
join in
that data about the answer so now we see
we have the same number of users which
makes sense right we're still doing a
left or into questions we're still doing
a first first after
but we have many fewer conversions
because we're excluding people who
answered after a week
so in this case 8.8 percent of people
answered a question within a week of
asking their first question
now you know we might change this up a
little bit and say well what about
answering a question before asking one
so all of this has been assuming you
know it goes question and then answer
but
of course there's nothing inherent in uh
this in this data and stack overflow
behavior that says someone couldn't
answer a question before asking so to do
this
we switch it up we now want answers to
be
the first table and questions for the
second because
answers is happening before questions we
change it to a right join because we
want to keep all the people asking
questions
and then again we summarize the
conversions and we summarize and we say
okay only people who had
um you know answered a question before
asking would be in the id
answer and we find that 4.63 percent of
people
answer a question before asking it and
here i just want to point out the type
argument being a first first
because we want to know okay someone's
first ever answer did that happen before
their first ever question
so in conclusion i want to talk about
why i created this package a little more
because the goals of funnel join is to
go from something that
is quote impossible to possible and i
put this in quotes because of course it
wasn't impossible before
right you know all the packages you have
it's possible because you're writing our
code that that supports those packages
but it could have been something that
maybe you didn't know how to do or even
if you could eventually figure
it out you know you thought it's just
going to take too long i don't want to
bother
um so this is just really hopefully
unlocking especially for
newer r users a whole new set of
questions and possibilities it's going
from something that
is time consuming and potentially error
prone to quick
and easy so as i showed at the beginning
you know it was all of these lines of
code all of these steps to
try to answer this question without
funnel joint and if you switched up the
question a bit you started having to
you know tweak a lot of parts of that
workflow and that could potentially lead
to some errors
versus funnels join the hope is that
this really makes it pretty quick and
easy
through things like of course the type
argument but also these extra arguments
like you want to know the time between
events
do gap call equals true you want to say
at most have this much time between
events
you can do the max get argument there's
also a min gap argument if you want
people
who say did the second event at least a
week afterwards
so funnel join is hopefully going to
make a lot of this process much easier
and finally going from limited
creativity to asking and answering new
questions so
what i mean by this is before i had
funnel join
i was not actually asking or getting the
answers to
nearly as many types of questions around
these sort of behavioral funnels
but once i had it once it became so easy
to just like get the answer
i realized i wasn't just you know more
quick and answering questions i was
thinking of so many more i was just
coming up with more things
uh because it sort of just unlocked this
creativity
in me and that's why for example
you know i think ggplot2 is so popular
and so great
is because it makes it so easy to you
know switch between different types of
graph to do this exploratory analysis
that it really you know enables you to
think of of lots of different things to
try it out because you know it's going
to be
you know so so quick and so so easy to
do so
if you want to learn more i have a blog
post
with that stack overflow data so all of
the uh the demo i did today
it's on this blog post on my blog
hookedondata.org
along with a little bit more explanation
there's also a vignette
that you can find on cran's website and
if you just google funnel join vignette
you'll find it
and it adds some more things like the
max gaap argument
and some additional functions that
funnel join has
as i mentioned i have my website hooked
on i'm also
on twitter at robinson underscore es
as i said you can find funnel join it's
both on cran and you can also find
it on github on my github robinson es
funnel join
and as i think jared's mentioned uh
unrelated to funnel join i also wrote a
book with jacqueline nola it's called
build a career in data science
uh which you can find at
datacycareer.com
and i think there's some free copies to
give away and you can also get 40
off with build book 40 with that thank
you all so much